hello a fragile ceasefire in gaza
appears to be holding egypt mediated the
deal between israel and the palestinian
group islamic jihad the u.n and qatar
were also involved in brokering that
truce at least 44 palestinians mostly
civilians were killed in the conflict
which began on friday 15 of them were
children the israeli government says it
was targeting members of the group
islamic jihad and it killed two of its
leaders during the offensive the armed
group responded by firing hundreds of
rockets into israel most were
intercepted by the iron dome missile
defense system
now the israeli strikes mostly hit three
areas in gaza the jubalia refugee camp
in the north where several people
including children and an elderly woman
were killed an agricultural area and
khan yunus in the south
and several sites in rafah along the
border with egypt those strikes killed
palestinian islamic jihad leader khalid
mansour
let's cross over to gaza and bring in
yumna sayid so yumna we understand now
that fuel trucks are entering gaza
as the crossings have reopened somewhat
yes doreen so uh we we learned from uh
the israeli side that they're going to
allow 30 fuel trucks to enter uh
throughout the day to the soul power
plant here behind me trucks have already
started arriving to
the power plant company to start
generating uh the electricity again as
it shut down yesterday sunday after uh
fuel was uh
deprived from entering for the past uh
six days so now as we witness the fuel
entering and the soul power plant
regenerating again we can we can find uh
like we can witness more electricity uh
uh coming to uh other facilities and
especially hospitals here in gaza
as this was the main issue that the
ministry of health was warning from and
as you mentioned it's a very fragile
calm that we are witnessing here people
are now uh
are now mourning more of the the their
loved ones that they have lost in the
past a few days in the israeli air
strikes and many as uh of the injuries
are in hospitals but as a development of
that cease fire when the the crossings
are opened also medical aid is entering
and humanitarian aid food supply is also
entering and the aries checkpoint has
been opened in front of the people who
want to uh come from israel into gaza uh
mainly the workers uh diplomats u.n
delegation who which has just arrived a
very short while ago into gaza uh the
u.n uh
humanitarian coordinator for gaza is
actually now for palestine is actually
now investigating the aftermath of the
israeli strikes in different areas of
the gaza strip all right thank you so
much
reporting from gaza
meanwhile in the occupied west bank
israeli forces have demolished
palestinian homes during a raid in the
north
bulldozers accompanied by israeli forces
destroyed two houses in the village of
ramanaian near janine
one belonged to the family of a
20-year-old palestinian who was one of
two men accused by israel of killing
three israelis
in may
let's cross over to west jerusalem we'll
get an update from there with john
holman so the ceasefire assumed that was
saying john appears to be holding in
gaza tell us what you're hearing from
your end
yeah definitely in southern israel as
well
where roads were closed where the trains
were stopped and where pretty much
everyone was going down to their shelter
that's opening up now as well as what
we're hearing the israeli president has
also gone down to visit those
communities in the south and has told
them that without them there's no state
of israel so sort of encouraging them um
in terms of the crossing and it opening
up the crucial thing obviously as well
is when workers will be allowed to go
from gaza into the state of israel
there's 14 000 people with work permits
to head into israel and obviously those
incomes are crucial
for their families for those families in
in gaza where there's a lot of
unemployment we've got in touch with the
israeli prime minister's office uh with
the military administration that deals
with uh that sort of thing especially
with relation to gaza and what we've got
back is just them saying that they're
going to evaluate uh and that um
that will that will depend on things
remaining calm that things will open up
further if the situation remains quiet
and calm i guess obviously they mean by
that if no more rockets come across the
other thing that israeli officials have
begun to say to israeli journalists
which is how news often percolates out
here is that they're seeing uh what
happened here is uh that they're getting
a signal that they've been getting
signals uh for weeks but not from
islamic jihad with whom they've
obviously had this escalation but from
hamas hamas is really the power that
controls gaza and hamas actually didn't
get involved directly in this
confrontation between islamic jihad and
the israeli government the israeli
government said that it has been saying
to reporters israeli reporters that uh
part of what it might be looking at is
how to move this forward and that could
involve prisoner swaps for example so
they're looking at how to move this
forward but not necessarily with islamic
jihad with whom this fragile ceasefire
is so far holding